feel like i just saw you mugs in the
hallway two hours 12 hours ago shaquille
o'neal
you need the chest accident 11 hours
charles barkley
we walked out of here about one and here
we are back i walked out at about 1 30
so
oh wow look at you working overtime and
you guys almost got me in trouble last
night
after the uh after the neato um here are
the two games we got for you on tnt this
afternoon bucks and the magic
followed by the pacers and the heat
for this pregame we thought it'd be kind
of fun because uh we got toronto
tomorrow night
uh on tnt uh raptors up three nothing
over the nets
uh and we asked nick nurse if he'd join
us here on the pregame show and nick was
kind enough to give us some time here so
nick thank you so much for taking that
time
good to see you i uh i have a question
guys
yeah i got a question for you um and
actually been doing some really deep
research um yeah you're the nba
champions
but also you're celebrating the 35th
anniversary
of a championship kemper catholic uh
in carroll ohio there he is in the front
row
wearing number 32 get some money nick
35 years ago 3a state champs in iowa and
you were
coached coached by the guy uh on the far
left
uh wayne chandley correct
yeah that's coach chanley over there
yeah wayne
brian david in the middle yeah yeah we
told
wayne that we were gonna be talking to
you today and he has a message for you
great hi nick it's coach chandler
hey congratulations on being
the nba coach of the year
for 2019 2020.
holy cow what an honor
very well deserved no staff
or coach works harder than you and your
staff
you are a class act and a very gracious
coach and you're always willing to give
back
congratulations
[Music]
thank you hey thanks a lot man that's
that's really cool
nick that's really cool man coach chan
he's a great man great
great man great coach and had him come
to
training camp just about every year for
for as long as i've been coaching back
in the states and
kind of all started with him so that's
really cool that he
he got to come on here today so thank
you for that appreciate it
you know uh there is a piece of hardware
that goes with that award
um and red hour back uh is on that
trophy and uh i understand that we have
a delivery person down there
uh with with the trophy um
if we can just wait for it wait for it
wait for it he's like looking around
what's going on i was wondering why you
guys wanted to talk to me today
like what do they want me on there for
today man well four no
of course we wanted to uh as as we wait
for the delivery of the trophy let me
ask you this because
uh your your path uh
to this award i mean you go from what
grand view
university naia school you were the head
coach when you were 23 so basically 30
years ago you're doing that
british basketball d-league g-league
and to where you are now who do you
start thinking about
who do you see here it comes the
delivery's coming
as you get there right here
[Laughter]
look at that man congratulations coach
okay couldn't have done it without these
guys that's for sure right you're
welcome
yeah man it's awesome awesome you almost
had a tear we seen it
i know i did coach stanley man you know
you've met him yeah you know
that's where it all started good time
coach appreciate it man i appreciate it
it's kayla
uh this is called trophy
yeah how's that thing look how's that
thing feel in your hands right there
well it's something i i know i know um
yeah it's it's something to to to be
here with this
um i mean it was it was quite amazing to
to be able to lift up that larry o'brien
trophy last year with these guys
uh that's for sure that one certainly
means
means the most to all of us to try to
get one of those
but this is this is cool and to have
those two guys as you as you guys know
they're
they're as tough and as smart and
competitive as it comes
and you don't do it without without
those kind of guys an amazing staff
amazing
organization and the other thing is
people of canada man i know they
they they support us really well so this
this goes out to them too
as i continue the question that i was
asking before
kyle lowry delivered the trophy so who
are the people that come to mind for you
when you when you think about the road
you've traveled
to get to this point
well i mean i start with my immediate
family first of all
you know my wife roberta my three sons
obviously
um my father was a was was a coach way
back when
uh coach chandley for sure that you
already saw
uh five older brothers you know beat the
beat the heck out of me every day and
toughened me up for life ahead
but but in a good way put me in a
competitive environment
coach elden miller at the university of
northern iowa for sure
dwayne casey who i started with under
here and a whole bunch of
other people and and and would be remiss
to not talk about nate bjorkman who's
been by my side for a couple titles one
in the d league one here
adrian griffin sergio scariola and and
the rest of my staff that
goes on and on they've they're really
amazing
you know when me and ernie were doing
our podcast uh we interviewed jill
madden
and he said you had came come and spend
some time with it and picking his
picking his brain who are some of the
other guys
who are great coaches managers like
coach man who you picked their brain
to incorporate into your style of
coaching
well i was lucky enough to get around to
to a few people joe was
joe i had some specific questions about
after reading a lot about him and i'm a
i'm a lifelong cubs fan so i was
i followed and read everything about him
you guys have probably heard i went and
spent
three days with phil jackson out in
montana that's another guy that i
studied a lot when i was in england
i used to get all the bulls tape shipped
in and
back when there was vhs tapes and watch
those over and over
um i went to see bill belichick
pete carroll sean mcvay
you know football guys i really like
following the the tactics and strategy
and leadership of the nfl too so
mix it up in the sports keeps it
interesting those guys were all very
gracious to
to let me come in and talk to them and
ask them questions
uh coach shack here first of all
congratulations well deserved
i'm anxious to know after the loss of
kawhi leonard
what was the conversation with your team
and did you pull ciaco in your office
and say guess what
with the emergence and how you played
last year this is your team now you're
the man
can you tell us a little bit a little
bit about the conversation you had with
your team
yeah well we were in vegas uh for summer
league when kauai
made that decision right and uh
literally the first two guys i saw were
fred van fleet and pascal ciaco and i
told them hey about 30 shots
opened up and they both they both
started swinging the rail they said they
were ready to
to fill the void there with those with
those open shots but
but um you know i think we had we had 22
games last year where we went 17 and 5
without them i think there was some
level that we could
we could be pretty decent right and i
think these guys
have all kind of stepped up a little bit
freddie norm
pascal came back to campus more mature
serge has had a great year kyle's you
know scored more than he did a year ago
they're all they're all really playing
og's been great
to insert in there too you know uh two
things uh what do you think the the
key for you know the leadership taking
going from a
assistant coach to going to a head coach
that six feet
is a lot it's a long walk sometimes and
sometimes the relationships that you
have with your players
as an assistant coach is much different
than you have
with your as a head coach how did you
take that six feet walk
and change your direction
well i think i think for for me what was
valuable ken as a head coach most of my
life
you know as as ernie mentioned earlier i
started at 23 as a head coach at small
college and
about 20 years as a head coach and that
was invaluable
to to be in front of a team you know
doing everything
chemistry substitute substitutions end
of game plays timeouts you know all that
for
you know a thousand games and then you
then you go be an assistant and
do the best you can to to help the head
guy with great ideas
but when i moved over i was i was pretty
comfortable i mean i know it's
it's a bigger deal certainly with the
nba and the relationship did
does change with those guys but i don't
know man you put you do your best to put
a great game plan for them
you try to put them in situations where
they can succeed you
you if something you say isn't right you
tell them man you messed it up and try
something else and and move on and just
keep on
doing the best you can for them nick
you've got an nba championship trophy
you've got
coach of the year trophy i'm thinking
the next thing
on your horizon may be a grammy award i
know you travel with your guitar and i
know the canadian band artel's had you
on stage playing guitar and you've also
played keyboards for them
so so tell me about this this musical
career taking off at the age of 53.
there's there's there's uh that is a a
hobby
uh only and it's uh i'm not much of a
musician but i love to play and
and uh keeps keeps me in my room on the
road is my big
biggest excuse i just i just love to do
it and uh kill some time and
relieve some of the the tension with it
really and uh those guys dragged me out
and do some stuff once in a while
well coach two also could coach could
you just tell us that you know
how you shaquille o'neal in the miami
heat influenced your coaching
could you just let us know about that
story again please
well so we were we were affiliated with
the miami heat when i was coaching at
the iowa energy
and the d-league and i went down to
watch
a couple practices and pat pat riley was
the head coach and
and i was sitting way down in the corner
because i couldn't get too close but i
was taking notes and
think of shaq and dee wade and we're
down there stretching working out and
shaq looked up at me and said who the
hell
are you i said i'm a coach in the d
league and he did say with the iowa
energy and i said yeah with the iowa
energy and uh
and he said he said something about
you're not writing a book are you and i
said no i'm just taking some notes
my first brush with shaq was it was it
was a classic one
my bad coach my bad that's great we
congratulate you
man we congratulate you nick so well
deserved
nba coach of the year and we'll we'll
see you on tnt tomorrow night and sorry
that we had to dupe you
into into appearing on our show it's
okay
thanks a lot man big surprise and really
grateful and humble to to receive the
every time you come on the show you're
not going to get an award like this
every time congratulations coach
congrats congrats have a good